good morning the failure to produce this
witness the failure to produce these
documents we consider yet additional
strong evidence of obstruction of the
constitutional functions of Congress a
co-equal branch of government there are
four issues that we are looking at at
least four issues that we are looking at
all that go to the heart of our national
security and by preventing us from
hearing from this witness and obtaining
these documents the President and
Secretary of State are taking actions
that prevent us from getting the facts
needed to protect the nation's security
we are looking into whether the
president solicited foreign help in a
u.s. presidential election again we are
looking into the issue of whether a
meeting that Ukraine desperately sought
with the president at the White House
was being conditioned on the willingness
of Ukraine to investigate this bogus
conspiracy theory about 2016 and
investigate the Biden's we're looking at
whether Ukraine was given reason to
believe that military assistance that
desperately needed to fight off the
Russians was being withheld until it
made commitments to do these political
investigations for the president and we
are looking into the question of whether
there has been an effort by the
President the Secretary of State and
others to cover up this misconduct
ambassador Sandlin is a important
witness on each of these subjects but he
is not the only important witness and we
will consider this act today and we've
had members flying in from around the
country to hear the ambassador's
testimony as well as the withholding of
the ambassador's documents as well as
efforts that may be made to discourage
or having the effect of discouraging
other State Department witnesses from
coming forward and testifying as they
have agreed to to be further acts of
obstruction of a co-equal branch of
government
this is one of the few impeachment
enquiries in the history of our country
it goes to the core of whether the
president abused his office to seek
political help in his reelection
campaign and did so to the detriment of
our nation's security did so by
effectively coercing a country that has
been invaded by Russia to investigate a
rival and condition the relationship
between this country and that country on
whether they were willing to play ball
that is the gravamen of the issues that
we are investigating that this
impeachment inquiry is looking into it
is hard to imagine a set of facts more
damaging to our national security and
our standing in the world but also more
of a fundamental breach of the
president's oath of office the American
people have the right to know if the
president is acting in their interests
in the nation's interest with an eye
towards our national security and not in
his narrow personal political interests
they have a right to know indeed the
American people have a need to know
and through this impeachment inquiry we
are determined to find the answers thank
you we understand the reason why the
State Department decided not to have
ambassador Sandlin appear today
i mean--you it's based on the unfair and
partisan process that mr. Schiff has
been running you think about what the
Democrats are trying to do impeach the
President of the United States thirteen
months prior to an election based on an
anonymous whistleblower with no
first-hand knowledge who has a bias
against the president and the guy
running the process chairmanship didn't
even tell us that he had met with the
whistleblower prior to the whistleblower
filing the complaint Adam Schiff didn't
tell us that the way he treated
ambassador Solomon last week in this
excuse me ambassador Volcker in this
interview last week
that's that treatment is the reason why
the administration in the State
Department said we're not going to sub
act ambassador's song into the same
treatment and look we were actually
looking forward to hearing from
ambassador Solomon we thought he was
going to reinforce exactly what
ambassador Volker told us last week but
again unfortunately when you have a
Speaker of the House who says we need to
strike while the iron's hot when you
have a chairman of the committee who is
so biased against this president that he
wouldn't even tell us that he had met
with his staff had met with the
whistleblower prior to the whistleblower
filing the complaint and frankly this is
a pattern with mr. Schiff he did the
same thing if you remember the first big
hearing the Democrats did this Congress
Michael Cohen he didn't tell his staff
had met with mr. Cohen for hours prior
to mr. Cohen testifying he didn't tell
us that last summer he had met with mr.
Simpson out in Colorado Palin while with
the guy of Houston GPS so this is a
pattern like I said we were hoping to
hear from the Ambassador today but we
understand exactly why the
administration exactly why the State
Department has chosen to say look if
it's going to be this kind of process if
you're going to selectively leaked text
messages 67 pages of text messages we
had they take a handful and release to
all of you and not give the full context
and not release the transcript we
understand why they made this this
decision at this at this moment